touchdown in LA to say California is
ready to welcome William and Kate would
be an understatement
royalty usurps even movie stardom here a
listers are queuing up to rub shoulders
with the Duke and Duchess the first in
line were fellow Brits David Beckham and
Stephen Fry at a glitzy reception at the
British consul generals residence where
Kate wore a dress by American designer
Diane von Furstenberg during their three
days in America there'll be plenty of
schmoozing and analysis of Kate's
wardrobe we'll go into overdrive they
started with a UK Trade and Industry
reception that clear a nod to the fact
that this visit has a purpose to promote
Britain in the u.s. the highlights of
their stay in America will be a charity
polo match and a BAFTA black-tie
reception but the most powerful
byproduct of all this will be the
complete affirmation of William and
Kate's superstar status the resounding
image held by Americans is the couple's
splendid fairytale wedding that
captivated the world having them here in
the flesh so soon after that is causing
a huge stir in a place that is itself
synonymous with celebrity Amanda
Walker's Sky News Los Angeles